20h53 on est en direct sur brut ce soir
on va vous faire vivre en direct le
lancement du vol habité de space x 7 à
21h 22h heure française ce sera à 15h22
hors local au centre spatial kennedy en
floride et pour m'accompagner s'asseoir
florence pour sept jours quand ça va
très bientôt mathy bon sérieusement un
peu particulier je pense qu'il ya un peu
de l'excitation un peu d'engouement
c'est sa publie ses historiques même
qu'ils aient envie de te dire historique
ouais bah ouais c'est historique parce
que à bon alors évidemment que les
américains sont déjà allés dans l'espace
tout seul mais là c'est pour la première
fois depuis neuf ans que des amériques
les astronautes américains partent du
sol américain avec une fusée américaine
et une capsule américaine donc c'est
voilà c'est depuis la fin des navettes
spatiales en fait tous les âges de tous
les astronautes américains partaient
avec les russes depuis baïkonour
donc là il ya vraiment une une
indépendance en termes de vols habités
qui reprend pour les américains ils sont
très contents
et en plus c'est historique parce que
c'est la première fois dans l'espace ya
le mondial que des astronautes vont
partir dans l'espace avec un vaisseau
élaboré par une entreprise privée et ça
va vraiment se limitera bien donc là on
est vraiment là bas c'est super et salue
toutes les personnes qui viennent nous
rejoindre sur ce live en faisait déjà
très nombreux 6300 sur facebook alors on
va aller on est aussi sûr sur youtube en
direct salue toutes les personnes qui
sont là sur ce live et vous dire que
cela il sait aussi le vôtre
donc n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
dans les commentaires même basique sur
tout et n'importe quoi n'hésitez pas à
réagir les commentaires partage
également ce direct avec vos proches un
peu moment historique florence essaiera
d'y répondre
l'ajustement avec pas mal pas mal de
choses à éclaircir ce soir je vais ce
site a d'ailleurs peut présenter pour
ceux aussi qui nous regardent oui
bonjour celles et ceux qui nous
regardent je m'appelle florence porcel
et jeu dans la vie je fais beaucoup de
vulgarisation scientifique et je suis
spécialisé dans le spatial donc voilà je
l'essayé de répondre à toutes vos
questions
généraliste là on voit le compte à
rebours il reste 28 minutes c'est ce que
je disais ya quelques instants le
décollage est prévu à 21h22 si tout va
bien si tout va bien parce que mercredi
justement il y avait un décollage de
prévu puis ça s'est pas fait c'est ça le
débat alors ça arrive très souvent et
spatiales c'est pas grave c'est juste
reporté
on a le même problème aujourd'hui c'est
des problèmes météo donc en fait ce qui
s'est passé mercredi c'est que les
conditions météo n'étaient pas bonnes
donc
préféré reporter le vol pour des
questions de sécurité il y avait en fait
y avait des risques de des clercs qui
pouvait arriver sur le lanceur donc la
fusée lanceur et fusées c'est la même
chose et donc ils ont préféré jouer la
sécurité et pas partir mais ce qu'il ya
c'est que la météo il la regarde pas
seulement sur le pack tire donc là d'où
part la suze et il faut vraiment aussi
que la météo soit bonne surtout toute la
durée du vol
jusque dans l'espace en fait qui en fait
qui qui part de floride qui va à peu
près jusqu'au dessus de l'irlande parce
que c'est dans cette partie c'est dans
cette portion du vol que les astronautes
peuvent s'éjecter en cas de problème et
donc si il s'éjecte il retourne dans
l'atlantique
et là il faut que la météo soit bonne
que les vagues soit pas trop hautes que
les ventes soient pas trop fort pour
pouvoir être récupéré par hélicoptère
si jamais ils ont eu besoin de s'éjecter
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut que la
météo soit bonne sur toute la
trajectoire de vol en tout cas jusqu'à
l'espace jusqu'à la dernière minute
c'est à dire que là par exemple à 21h15
on peut nous dire c'est pas bon ouais et
puis même à 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
no go et là bas une seconde à vendre on
peut très bien décider de ne pas partir
alors je me pose une question très
basique
21h22 pourquoi a dit pourquoi 21h22 et
pas 22h40 je parle heure française parce
que leur local ce sera exactement
15h22 là exactement il l'est 14h56 sur
place exacte alors 21h 22h de paris
parce que en fait il faut partir une
heure précise pouvoir l'objectif alors
les astronautes qui sont dans ce
vaisseau vont dans la station spatiale
internationale et la station spatiale
internationale
elle n'est pas fixe elle tourne autour
de la terre et donc le but du jeu c'est
évidemment d'aller la rejoindre et situ
par une ligne notamment où il me tape
une minute après tu la loupe
bon en fait voilà l'orbité calculer le
temps est calculé en fonction de
l'orbité delà de la vitesse de la
station spatiale internationale autour
de la terre de la terre qui tourne la
vitesse de la fusée enfin bref tout un
tas de facteurs jolie équation qui font
que du coup l'heure de départ c'est
21h22 et pas une minute plus tard
alors on n'a pas eu de plusieurs
fenêtres de tir justement donc mercredi
où c'est un échec ça a été reporté à
samedi
mais si jamais là on voit que les
conditions alors plutôt pas mal mais si
jamais ça ne fonctionnait pas à 21,22 il
y aurait une autre fenêtre de tir de van
der sar demain à 21 heures pile locale
there et coûtent 15 heures heure locale
bah oui parce qu'il faut toujours
attraper la station spatiale
internationale et donc elle se décale un
petit peu sur leurs buts à chaque fois
faire un petit peu complexe mais en gros
le calcul fait que les mains si si ça
paraît demain passe pas prédire à
attentif lorsqu'il est important
d'expliquer et ce qu'il fait aussi
l'engouement ce soir c'est que c'est la
première fois qu'une mission habitée est
opérée par une société privée
c'est le premier vol habité aux usa
depuis novembre donc ça fait quand même
pas mal de contexte qui rend les choses
un peu historique qui donne aussi un
engouement
bah c'est ça les américains sont super
contents parce que les américains savent
bien leur pays j'aime bien leur nation
et oui effectivement et surtout il
n'aime pas trop dépendre de qui que ce
soit mais des russes
encore moins puisque voilà on connaît la
rivalité historique même si en fait
cette rivalité elle est toute relative
parce que dans le domaine du spatial
depuis 1975 en fait c'est une
collaboration entre les états unis et la
russie qui se passe bien donc on part
plus qu'on ne parle plus de conquête
spatiale depuis 1975 mais de
d'exploration spatiale si ces patients
en 1975 c'est que il ya eu la mission
apollo soyouz donc à une capsule apollo
du côté des américains une capsule
soyouz
du côté des russes et soviétiques à
l'époque qui sont à marie l'une à
l'autre dans l'espace et la crap s'est
ouverte entre les deux vaisseaux et
l'astronaute américain et le cosmonaute
russe se sont serré la pince dans
l'espace au dessus de metz
d'ailleurs au dessus de la france et à
partir de là voilà c'était la fin de la
guerre froide en tout cas au niveau du
spatial en 75 donc depuis
soixante-quinze c'est vraiment des
collaborations les la station mir
ensuite la station spatiale
internationale etc
mais quand même les américains il aime
bien dépendre de personne en fait pour
envoyer leurs propres astronautes dans
l'espace
et donc ils sont content de récupérer
cette indépendance en termes de vols
habités
et effectivement ce qu'il ya de nouveau
c'est le privé donc la nasa a envoyé un
appel d'offres en 2000 je crois que
c'était en 2010 si je dis pas de bêtises
et donc des tas d'entreprises ont
répondu et elle a sélectionné deux
entreprises donc space x et boeing pour
développer une capsule habitée donc
habiter ça veut dire avec des gens
dedans
et voilà et donc on en est là c'est le
premier vol de ce pays 6 ce soir on
l'espère et puis la capsule de boeing
le vol d'essai à vide s'est pas très
bien passé donc y en aura un autre pour
j'espère un premier vol habité boeing la
côte et scientifique mais aussi la
rivalité politique on parle beaucoup
justement c'est concurrence entre pays
les états unis la chine la russie
c'est quoi ce soit pour les usa c'est de
montrer qu'on est les meilleurs que nous
non ben non parce qu'ils sont allés sur
la lune veut dire y'a pas de bâtons par
exemple s'il ya non et puis en fait
c'est pas tant que ça parce que
jusqu'ici les russes sont les meilleurs
aussi parce que c'est leur lanceur en
terme de deux capsules et de deux
lanceurs habitées sont sont les
meilleurs du monde ils sont les plus
fiables c'est pour ça que ça marche très
bien depuis des années thomas pesquet
lui même est parti dans un soyouz russes
dans une fusée soyouz russes donc ça
marche très bien donc
en fait chacun est meilleur dans un
domaine donc et pas vraiment de rivalité
au contraire ils s'entraînent tous les
uns les autres
c'est un peu différent pour la chine qui
est quand même émergentes mais
globalement dans le spatial c'est plutôt
une collaboration qui pacifique qui se
passe très très bien et d'ailleurs la
station spatiale internationale c1 c'est
un argument diplomatique extrêmement
fort parce que quand ça va pas entre les
deux pays sur terre ils sont obligés de
s'entendre parce qu'ils savent que dans
l'espace ils n'ont pas le choix ils
n'ont pas le choix parce qu'il ya des
gars à eux
si vous entendez bien dans les
commentaires on peut saluer toutes et
tous il est 21 heures à paris il est 15
heures deux au centre spatial kennedy en
floride
le décollage est prévu si tout va bien à
21h 22h le suivant sans vous avez ce
compte à rebours y est tout doucement de
diminuer 20 minutes 19 la fumée la guise
des gages l'a6 et de la vapeur
rien de rien d'anormal c'est les
différences de température entre l'air
et
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur donc tout va
bien
rien d'anormal fait normal qu'ils
faisaient je suis et oui c'est normal
qu'une cuvée ces mêmes professionnels à
ses ratios de fumée voilà donc ça c'est
les derniers préparatifs 19 minutes on
voit le couloir d'accès alors je ne sais
pas s'ils ont décalé je sais pas
exactement à quand même temps avant le
vol il était calme et je crois que les
deux cas les là parce que sinon on
devait on verrait arriver vraiment à
l'endroit de la capsule puisque c'est le
couloir mettre ses créations sont
empruntés pour rentrer dans la capitale
en tout en 19 minutes
j'espère tout va bien là que vous
entendez bien que se passe bien au
niveau du sol tout ça dit moi dans les
commentaires voilà 19 minutes on veut
les conditions météorologiques qui sont
plutôt pas mal et pas mal de parler de
l'effet 6 justement c'était un peu des
ascenseurs un peu si l'émotionnel c'est
ça ouais bah oui parce qu'en fait les
spéciales sont l'expression consacrée
et en fait personne mais six comme l'aja
social russe où la nasa du 20 personnes
et une fusée du premier c'est tout le
monde s'est pété des trucs aux dépens
donc c'est tout à fait normal que au
début les premières les premiers tests
ont explosé en fin ça fait partie du
truc
donc effectivement jeu n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille mais franchement
ils ont fait en moins de 20 ans des
choses complètement ahurissante à lui
risque et des choses que personne
n'avait jamais fait mieux c'est à dire
que ce site et ce sont les seuls au
monde public et privé red bull à avoir
fait des lanceurs de fusées qui
reviennent à la verticale au sol ou sur
une barge dans l'atlantique comme cela
est le cas ce soir
voilà avant juste mais refusé par terre
et ensuite soit le retombé dans l'océan
soit avec des morceaux qu'ils restent
nerveux arbitres
donc là il récupère les parties
principales de détruire les photos de
ces bêtes c'est comme si vous y étiez
les amants à la poubelle à chaque fois
que vous faites un vol
bah là c'est pareil pour les touts les
nouvelles règles titulaire ça réduit des
instances p 4 c'est vrai que l'on va
parler de lui notamment en ligue europa
alors est ce que sarkozy ce sport il est
important d'expliquer que ça n'a
absolument rien à voir avec tout va bien
ces deux programmes totalement différent
c'est qu'il a explorés hier soir oui
hier c'est un pro de test donc ce n'est
pas un ingrat visé juste un prototype et
c'est quelque chose qui soit juste que
justement en cours d'élaboration en
cours de textes en cours de test c'est
un double moteur c'est un nouveau
système d'oublier ça m'a complètement
passif est complètement fausse et n'a
rien à voir avec ce qui se passe
maintenant lorsqu'on voit l'image c'est
donc une fusée qui s'appelle john thain
elle vole des années elle est fiable
tout se passe bien il ya très très peu
de problèmes ces dernières années donc
tout va bien et la capsule l'un sur
halak a fixé le dragon a été testé en
conditions réelles alors à vide et
évidemment sans personne à l'intérieur
on le remarque à peine 50 des terres
mais sans être humain à l'intérieur tous
les tests ont été concluants c'est pour
ça que la nasa a donné son feu vert ce
soir pour faire ce vol de démonstration
avec des astronautes à s'accélérer ce
qui est des risques juste rimont c'est
ça et ça quand on voit ça on this et des
technologies est très importante
comment ce qu'il est chaque de risque
particulier oui alors en fait un cahier
des charges de la nasa ce que la nasa
demande donc à ses à ces entreprises qui
qui qui m'ont fait venir des capsules
c'est de ne pas dépasser un certain
seuil de risque c'est à dire que pour la
nasa
il faut pas que ça dépasse un risque sur
270 père de l'équipage au lieu de servir
ce désastre
donc là la caf
ces calculs et à un risque sur 273 en
dessous évidemment que ça a été un
solide c'est vrai qu'on les avait pas
valide mais il ya un autre risque quel
touriste et le risque de perdre la
mission c'est à dire que sans danger
pour les astronautes
et donc elle l'a remis à sur terre hamas
est mariée et sans que les expériences
et plus on appelle donc la cerise et de
1 sur 60 musée le suis donc voilà il ya
de risque qui s'est appuyé le risque et
il risque de faire avorter la diva qui
est moins grave
c'est embêtant travers monsieur toutes
les personnes qui nous regardent c'est
important ça veut dire là on est à peu
près à 15 minutes qui maintenant 14
minutes et 10 secondes dans les derniers
préparatifs qui sont là les commentaires
n'hésitez pas à réagir à se poser mais
nous a posé de suivre également
on essaye justement de vous répondre
n'hésitez pas voilà je vois pas mal de
commentaires mais une salut merci d'être
là en chicane photo c'est le flotteur
son cours puis 160 euros axa a lancé
il a fait de la falcon heavy sur nous
mais en fait je sais pas si c'est une
femme comme nine avec un peu créances et
autres engrais deux autres talk on gagne
donc ça fait trois fois neuf moteurs les
fans se posèrent pour qu'une fusion et
si vous voulez regarder ça sur youtube
c'est absolument incroyable puisque
cette survol de ce test réussi de la
fusée a décollé et non seulement ça
s'est bien passé mais inclut les deux
boosters donc sur les côtés donc deux
fois 9 moteurs sont revenus à la
verticale sur le
tir au même moment le principe c'est un
spectacle ou de la science-fiction
c'est visible sur youtube sur la chaîne
de space x quand c'est absolument
extraordinaire ce qui est important de
dire ce que c'est que ce soir donc la
fusée va revenir
elle revient elle revient sur terre
après le décollage
elle sera de retour sur terre c'est
comme ça c'est bien sûr une barge qui se
trouve dans la partie parce que le sang
fait des comme ça se détache la fusée et
avec la capsule sous de boulay ajoutant
ou la prison effectivement la capsule ce
cas qu'elle s'assoit partir du bois là
c'est le fait la capsule en comblant
ensuite par type la capsule ensuite la
partie blanche dubois en dessous du noir
ça c'est du deuxième étage du lanceur ne
se détache pas tout de suite mais ce
qu'il ya en dessous
c'est le premier étage c'est ça qui
revient sur terre donc c'est la plus
grande partie c'est vraiment la plus
grande partie du lanceur qui revient sur
terre et donc il reviendra au jeu c'est
long je pense que ouais alors du
décollage jusqu'à l'arrivée à la station
spatiale internationale c'est 19h19
croit alors c'était 19 heures il ya
trois jours peut-être que c'est un peu
moins mais c'est à peu près ça c'est à
peu près ça mais du moment où elles
décollent au moment où ils sont sur la
bonne orbite ne laisse pas sur la bonne
route
il ya huit mois
tu veux la station se trouve à 400 km au
dessus de la note est donc allé à 400 km
d'altitude à peu près entre 380 et moi
donc c'est 400 km d'altitude
mais si tu veux encore une fois on ne va
pas en ligne droite ça n'existe pas les
lindgren l'espace c'est vraiment des
lignes court parce qu'il faut il faut
suivre la courbure de la terre et donc
en fait ils font le tour de la terre
avant de rejoindre la station c'est pour
ça que ça dure 19 heures
d'ailleurs plusieurs fois le tour de la
terre pourra vraiment être sur la bonne
orbite parce qu'à chaque fois il monte
un petit peu en altitude à chaque fois
qu'ils font une orbite autour de la
terre
en fait c'est que c'est comme ça que ça
se passe c'est vraiment pas une ligne
droite c'est plusieurs tours à chaque
fois on augmente leur jusqu'à
arriver à la bonne orbite de là où se
trouve la station et que les deux
vitesse relative de la station et de la
capsule soit à peu près les mêmes pour
éviter un accident
la vitesse et conviendra peut pas se
déterminer
alors ils sont l'aviation spatiale sa
vitesse c'est à peu près 28 mille
kilomètres heure passée dans l'espace il
n'y a pas d'air pour l'année voilà et si
elle est l'élève moins rapidement elle
tomberait en fait c'est grey sur terre
simplement il faut qu'elle aille cette
vitesse et donc il faut que la capsule
atteignent cette vitesse là pour pouvoir
la rejoindre et être à peu près à la
même vitesse
à quelques mètres par seconde près pour
pouvoir vraiment s'amarrer en douceur
alors on évoquait les enjeux au début on
évoque beaucoup l'idée de deux vols
commerciaux se dire que peut-être dans
quelques années ou dans quelques
décennies on ira sur la lune sur la
planète mars ou que sais-je
c'est c'est envisageable c'est par ce
genre d'événement aujourd'hui qu'on
avance vers ça ou alors oui non en fait
là c'est vraiment là on est vraiment sur
un vol avec des astronautes
professionnels dans un programme de la
nasa donc il veut envoyer des
astronautes professionnels
maintenant ça reste une à une la capsule
d'une entreprise privée et donc si elle
fonctionne space x aura des capsules
privé dont ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent puisque c'est leur capsule
donc si un jour ils ont envie d'utiliser
cette capsule pour un vol touristique
qui vendent à des as
ad
à des particuliers très riche où ils
peuvent le faire mais là en tout cas
c'est une agence spatiale qui demande
une vol pour des astronautes
professionnels
donc là on est à 9 minutes parce qu'il
ya juste un qui me parle je ne comprends
pas ce qu'il me dit j'ai vraiment il
faut que tu parles très fort ah ouais
bah j'ai en fait oui je viens dans mon
casque le retour de la nasa pour avoir
les les les infos c'est pas facile de
discuter avec toi belle anglaise
on peut jusqu'à même 10 secondes dire ah
bah finalement moi je
très expérimentés ont déjà faire
plusieurs vols dans l'espace pour
vraiment avoir les galets plus les plus
expérimentés quoi pour être sûr on peut
pas envoyer quelqu'un qui est jamais
allé dans l'espace
il vaut mieux des gens qui savent ce que
ça déjà donc voila voila pour le choix
de ces deux astronautes doug hurley
c'est aussi symbolique parce qu'il a
fait partie de la dernière mission d'une
navette spatiale qui s'appelait atlantis
et qui est donc c'était la dernière
navette à partir du sol américain donc
il ya neuf ans le dernier vol qui est
partie du sol américain habité il y
avait vu un peu donc c'est symbolique
que là il repart en neuf ans plus tard
dans le premier vol américain et son
meilleur pote bob behnken bonsoir à
toutes et tous 21h16 qui reste 58 avant
le avant le décollage
donc là c'est vraiment les toutes
dernières minutes où parlait justement
des expés ces deux personnes laura
justement est ce qui empêche lui qu'est
ce que nous croyons pas 70 ans être en
bonne condition qui vous y allez dans la
preuve ça a été fait zhang jianyong
affine a une mission dans une navette
spatiale à plus 70 ans de john young
c'est un des astronautes qui a marché
sur la lune
donc voilà oui alors il avait un médecin
de bord etc
mais oui oui bien sûr que si on a la
bonne condition physique on peut alors
c'était une exception de nouméa plus 70
ans mais oui oui non mais tant que les
conditions physiques
on parle là de lanta 6 boeing 747 pas ce
que c'est qu'un 147 la poussée angers
alors en fait si c'est comme dans le
soyouz le maximum de la pensée c'est
autour de 3,4 g 1 g en fait c'est l'axé
l'accélération de la de la pesanteur ce
marché sur le sol terrestre explique en
gros ils sont là les informer que vous
voyez sur la viola maire de sautiller
d'être très léger parce que parce que la
gravité sur la nuit
la mine et un petit corps moins massif
et donc là la planète terre est plus
faible
on parle de 1/6 de la gravité on les en
gros il pas simplement un jour sur mars
on pèse trois fois moins lourd que sur
terre bon mais on peut aussi poser
beaucoup plus lourd quand vous êtes dans
une voiture et que vous accélérez très
fort comme dans un joli et dans une
voiture ça marche aussi
vous êtes coller au siège et là vous
avez prudent j'ai souvenir que vous avez
une accélération
c'est plus grande que l'accélération qui
nous colle les pieds où sa voix parce
qu'on tombe en permanence jusqu'au
dégagement au pied du ccsa
l'accélération un jour est donc dans la
fusée à un moment du vol les astronautes
vont vivre 3,4 g et donc ces trois à
quatre fois leur poids donc s'il pèse 80
kg ben en fait le calcul si l'on croyait
être en faillite 24,6 ils auront
l'impression de peser 240 kilos et je
t'assure que c'était chaud parce que moi
j'ai fait un vol en apesanteur et la
l'accélération c'était seulement un
petit peu en dessous de 2 g donc moi je
pèse 50 kg j'avais l'impression de peser
100 dans le même corps c'est bizarre le
banc tpe
je suis pas sûr a l'impression qu'on a
les joues qui s'y colle rejoindre le sol
on a du mal à lever le bras parce que
les hinton on a du mal à parler parce
que dans cette paisible où donc ouais
3,4 g c'est joli accélérations mais dans
le nom ils vont jusqu'à 8 g je crois
vous n'aviez donc ils sont entraînés
bien plus que ce qu'ils doivent
il en fait ils rient ils sont entraînés
toujours pire que ce qu'ils vivent
comment un vol en revanche si s'éjecte
là je crois qu'ils prennent pendant
quelques secondes une fraction de
seconde
pas mal de g je crois que ça peut aller
jusqu'à 10 ou 12 en tout cas en soyouz
là pour cette capsule là je sais pas
mais ça peut être assez violent donc
ouais alors ses entraînements et je dis
bon soin à toutes les personnes qui
viennent nous rejoindre vous voyez le
compteur il est là il est à l'image
trois minutes et 5 secondes hanks et
imminent pour l'instant tout à l'air de
bien se passer tout est préparé on
parlait de cette fumée c'était
intéressant peut-être d'en reparler pour
ceux qui viennent de nous rejoindre
maintenant tout en disant à toutes les
personnes
n'hésitez pas à commenter à partager
sociaux qu'on soit encore plus nombreux
à vivre ce moment qu'on explore avec
avec son rang ce qui est venu jusqu'ici
pour nous parler d'eux de collage qui
domine on s'est vus mais à l'image juste
la différence entre la température
extérieure qui est assez élevé en
floride et le carburant à l'intérieur
qui mettrait à très très basse que celle
ci j'ai un liquide qui je crois je vais
dire une bêtise mais c'était vraiment
une température très très très négative
donc il ya un type différent je suis
comme vous avez de l'eau de la vapeur en
fait tout simplement ce serait trop
chaude et l'air est moins chaud et donc
ça fait de la vapeur donc tous
j'ai compris
ouais en fait le il faut que le ton qui
s'installe ça prend un peu de temps
il faut le temps de vérifier que la
capsule soit en bon état en bonne santé
on dit faut la fermer hermétiquement il
faut vérifier qu'elle est un métier que
la pression va bien failli et les pas de
vérifications à faire et donc il faut
vraiment qu'ils s'y prennent tôt
patiemment voilà on est à moins d'une
minute
c'est plus la pêche aux moules mais
c'est fou et à aimer autant il ya des
êtres humains à l'intérieur
déjà que quand c'est que voilà c'est un
enjeu est apparemment plus les biens
dont 35 seront alors prêts est lancé
trente secondes
alors là on va péter les watts et calais
et donc huit minutes après le lancement
on va voir la fusée revenir sur terre
sur la barge en atlantique pour rester
debout ce qu'il a dit on va on va faire
vivre les 10 secondes avec la partie à
dix mois on va voyager avec eux et avec
eux j'ai tout ce qui nous suivent
ibos police en cas de mauvaises
techniques qu un portrait des nectars
[Musique]
ce type flux mais en gros il ya tout
d'expliquer sur cette planète
voilà on est avec sur la maxe qse le
maximum
attention comme c'est le moment le plus
dangereux pour la cuisine parce qu'elle
comporte de très cotés donc c'est
vraiment critique ce moment critique
il va y avoir la séparation avant ça
peut arriver ça revient au même salon
depuis longtemps il faudra surtout avec
3000 sont refusés le pam et alain valet
pas retrouver mélangés la cour les fuit
depuis hier je suis impressionné ce
qu'il ressent ah oui cette accélération
donc là je pense qu'ils sont à 2 2 3 pen
à bâle après seulement je pense qu'ils
sont très très très lourd accélération
qui sont vraiment collé à leur siège et
sa voix vibre et voilà qu'on voit la
terre et là tu vois c'est la caméra qui
à l'intérieur du lanceur donc on va voir
le premier étage se détacher à gauche de
l'écran 3 millions va le voir
voilà il se défend
redescend sur terre ils n'ont pas droit
que c'est bon pour est déjà une soul
déjà très bon et ben tu vois
l'altitude c'est la pause entre les
passants l'espace c'est que ça n'a rien
à voir là me plains pas sincère et
l'atmosphère devenait en bout oui à
partir de ils sont en impesanteur enfin
en apesanteur
ça dépend parce qu'ils accélèrent encore
le moteur qu'on voit à droite ça les
pousse encore on l'a fonctionnement qui
sont encore en train d'accélérer voilà
qui sont encore en scène et sellerie
donc ils sont pas en imprécateur parce
qu'il ya derrière il ya quelque chose
qui l'est plus donc ils sont toujours
collés à leur siège
c'est quand le moteur s'éteindra que là
ils seront en apesanteur parce que rien
ne les poussera plus les motos et c'est
un embout de maintenant ça on verra là
je sais pas j'ai pu les chiffres exacts
mais on le verra s'éteindre de toute
façon donc là on a 150 2 km d'altitude
et on aimerait bien avoir les images du
premier étage qui redescend sur terre
parce que là il est en train de retomber
il retombait également après all
priorise les images sur le may valorise
l'image à gauche effectivement sur les
lancements dans la capsule
ça c'est impressionnant lorsqu'on vit
c'est un moment assez
c'est historique c'est seulement
historique et même en change d'air on
change d'heure parce que vraiment le
privé c'est la première fois et
jusqu'ici tout va bien donc en fait on a
passé la phase critique là c'est à dire
que là les astronautes sont dans
l'espace dont ils n'ont plus besoin de
s'éjecter de revenir dans le goût de
revenir dans l'atlantique tout de suite
en tout cas
donc donc vraiment on a passé le plus
dur le danger est moindre le danger est
moindre qu'estime la phase critique
c'était vraiment avant leur décollage
et tant qu'on n'est pas dans l'espace on
n'a pas senti le 100 km à peu près de
100 km qui sont caen vannes oc voyages
en france et des attestations là c'est
le 100km b
bientôt vers le haut tout à l'air de
bien se passer dans la capsule
voilà là à droite on voit les images du
premier étage qui redescend sur terre et
donc un vin sokol de sécurité parce que
j'imagine que ça doit pas tomber
n'importe où ces instants aussi c'est
calculé il ya des petits des petits
propulseurs des petits moteurs qui
lancent des piques de temps en temps
pour remettre aux droits en fait pour ça
pour se remettre droit par rapport à là
où il doit descendre et la barge et donc
qui s'appelle alors la barge elle
s'appelle of course inscrit le view
c'est son nom elle se trouve dans
l'atlantique est
ces dernières années à chaque fois qu'il
ya eu un retour de premier étage donc
sur la barge of course à still love you
ça s'est très bien passé et ça arrive
vraiment pile au milieu de la croix sur
la barge quoi c'est vraiment
impressionnante c'est vraiment on se
demande comment c'est possible et c'est
des calculs et voilà c'est c'est
évidemment de l'ingénierie c'est du
travail de centaines de milliers de
personnes mais ça marche ça marche
alors on a nos éminents les commentaires
qui m'ont ce qu'on ne devrait pas
pouvoir la voir depuis chez nous c'est
là qu'on va pouvoir l'observer à un
moment donné la capsule la capsule mais
là avec les astronautes dedans je pense
pas qu'on puisse la voir il a une et je
pense qu'il faut des jumelles
parce qu'elle sera pas assez brillante
pour qu'on puisse la voir elle est la
station la station spatiale on peut la
voir
bien sûr régulièrement des fois les pass
de trois fois par part soit on peut la
voir même à paris un même dans les
villes où il ya de la beaucoup de
pollution lumineuse c'est tellement
lumineux que on la voit très bien leur
nu c'est comme une grosse étoile
brillante mais qui qui passe dans le
ciel d'ouest en est en trois entre trois
et quatre minutes
23h12 web en passant par 12 pour toute
la france en fait toute la france toute
la france elle arrivera donc la station
spatiale
on la verra arriver à 23h12 depuis
l'ouest et en quatre minutes
elle fera le tour du fer le elle
traversera le ciel vers l'est
donc on avait à travailler à l'oeil nu
et ça pour le savoir en fait c'est assez
magique de le voir et c'est vraiment
accessibles à tous partout à l'oeil nu
il ya une application il ya des
applications qui existent pour avoir les
heures de passage il la direction de
vous regarder à
moi j'ai un iphone donc ça s'appelle iss
potter mais il ya des mêmes pour android
on peut avoir les heures de passage
comme les heures de passage dans donc
voilà on sait que en france est 23ème
tous les soirs et la capsule sera pas
très loin mais je doute qu'on puisse la
branche c'est compliqué d'avoir le voilà
le moteur du premier étage s'allume à
droite là pour ralentir
en fait il accélère ça sert à accélérer
la fusée vers le haut
donc pour la ralentir par rapport à son
à sa chute puisque la vitesse continuent
de s'emballer serre que là je vous là on
va regarder de la capsule jeudi pour
ceux qui nous regardent vous avez
plusieurs indicateurs
vous avez le mes pronos 17 minutes et 44
secondes c'est le temps de recul des
collages ses 198 km c'est la latitude de
la fusée actuellement la gauche vous
avez la vitesse la vitesse ça soit 28
c'est totalement dingue que même si ça
fait chier sur le périphérique ça ne
s'alarmaient la seo nador c'est
invisible passait sa part aux dés sont
toujours sur terre et j'espère que le
temps sera assez bon là on va
retraverser les nuages et j'espère qu'à
un moment on va vraiment voir la barge
sur l'atlantique à voir arriver de plus
en plus proche c'est vraiment super
impressions et ont eu là pendant ce
temps là qui sont à l'intérieur ils ont
des retours on sent vraiment je pense
qu'ils sont en communication hamas en a
perdu la caméra sur la première et à
venir eux dans la capsule
il transporte toujours en lien avec le
sol mais je trouve que l'on volé
automatique pour l'instant ils ont rien
à toucher puisque tout va bien priori
c'est donc là ils vont rejoindre dans 19
heures c'est ça la station spatiale dans
19 heures donc demain je vais faire quoi
l'intérieur c'est quoi la suite du
programme
alors en fait pendant cinq heures et
demie ils pourront faire des
vérifications regarder la barre là la
barre jean va sûrement voir arriver les
ans le premier étage qui va arriver
normalement il est arrivé jusqu alors
normalement si tout se passe bien
jusqu'ici donc normalement devrait le
voir arriver et en parler on a la
vitesse de la fusée qui rentrent le
stabiliser aux alentours de 27 mai on a
perdu le signal sur le sur la barge
l'image du lanceur enfin du premier
étage debout sur la barge
on verra bien mais c'est bien et ça
tombe pile à l'endroit il ya un serbe
choses et des gens dedans donc la
première fois que jean récupérer un
premiers étages de lanceurs d'engins
lancement avec les gens de ces grands
premières places et reculent à la c1
mais ces foules balas et une première
oui parce que dans il les récupère si tu
veux mais avant il n'y avait pas de gens
dans la fusée là il ya la laci coup
c'est vrai pardon je crie beaucoup mais
l'émotion est belle parce que il y en a
beaucoup qui la partagent en ce moment
les commentaires du tout jusqu'ici tout
va bien tout se passe nickel comme il le
comme il l'espérait donc c'est vraiment
le vol idéal jusqu'ici donc et dans mon
cas ça y est ils sont en en faisant
taire regarde on voit les petits le
petit allait le petit dinosaure et
petites peluches flottait donc ça y est
ils sont imposantes heures donc
apesanteur c'est au tour de là on est à
200 km là il souhaite vraiment être
d'altitude donc à 200 kilomètres au
dessus de nos têtes et ils vont donc ils
vont à 27 milles kilomètres heure parce
que la fusée les à accélérer jusque là
donc les moteurs delà du deuxième étage
de la fusée se sont coupés c'est pour ça
que là il n'accélère plus donc là ils
sont lancés donc comme dans l'espace ya
pas deux il n'y a pas d'air c'est vide
y'a rien qui les freine mais rien qu'il
n'y a pas de frottement avec l'air qui
puisse les freiner donc ils ont cette
vitesse là et voilà qu'ils garderont
pour pour s'amarrer ensuite à la station
spatiale sommes pas tout à fait quand on
compte justement quand on a 7 7 puis
sans cela les les deux personnes à bord
il doit il peut manger boire avant on
leur dit de couper les vivres
alors on dirait qu'ils ont le mal
demeure ou
de montag à 100 km heure c'est fini à 90
par don de 500 des astronautes aguerris
cela dit les astronautes peuvent être
malade ça arrive c'est déjà arrivé mais
a priori cela non
donc ils prennent un solide petit
déjeuner quand même parce que il ya même
un solide déjeuner parce qu'ils sont
partis donc à 15 heures donc il était
dans la capsule à vers 12h30 d'autres
comme ça donc voilà il faut quand même
être en forme
je sais pas s'ils ont quelque chose pour
boire à l'intérieur de leur casque je
pense pas en tout cas ce qu'il ya c'est
que alors voyager longtemps cdc oui
c'est pas aux dinosaures ils sont
attachés comme ça ça non au bout d'un
moment ils vont pouvoir se détacher et
aller normalement si c'est comme dans le
soyouz même si je connais moins bien
cette capsule parce que encore une fois
c'est la première fois qu'on utilise
donc là je la connais moins bien ils
vont pouvoir se détacher et allées
dallées je pense se retirer leurs
combinaisons je crois qu'ils auront
droit et puis bah voilà être en tee
shirt
ah voilà le de pardon le deuxième étage
de la fusée se détache de la capsule
donc enfin voilà en ce moment et donc
normalement la capsule est tout seul
donc là c'était le deuxième moteur et
savoir où ça ça retombe savoir tomber ça
va retomber way est aussi pareil monde
façon millier d'inscrits non là ça va
soit ça brûle dans l'atmosphère soit il
s'il en reste des morceaux ça retourne
dans le sac il ya aucun risque que ça
tombe sur des habitations ou autre il ya
toujours un risque mais jusqu'ici ces
jamais arrivé c'est je me rêvais sauf
les chinois qui font un peu n'importe
quoi c'est une autre c'est une autre
affaire mais en gros voilà au pdg par
exemple avec avec en chine par exemple
des actions de type wii donc cette
seconde capitaux de saisir voir ailleurs
dans le monde afrique ou en france un
peu moins là comme ça décolle aux états
unis ça peut arriver jusqu'en france si
jamais il ya eu une erreur en web à la a
priori c'est calculé pour que ça tombe
dans l'océan si jamais ça ne brûle pas
dans l'atmosphère mais a priori ça ça va
revivre l'atmosphère c'est ce à quoi
sans méthode si on sait ce que c'est
si vous trouvez un petit bout chez vous
ça peut valoir de l'or en tout cas mes
craintes normalement sacrement
l'atmosphère et donc pendant cinq heures
et demie après le décollage
ils font les to qui
eh bien tous les potes cheikh y vérifie
la capsule va bien calé en forme cas pas
de problème
il travaille pendant cinq heures et demi
et ensuite on leur demande d'aller se
reposer donc ils auront huit heures de
sommeil et ils seront réveillés demain
pour tout le processus de rendez vous
avec la station spatiale
mais ils ont huit heures de sommeil
lancé 19 heures de vol donc ça c'est
assez rapide jeu via les commentaires
qu'ils réagissent et quelques instants
qui disait florence elle est contente
comme si c'était la france qui a marqué
en finale de coupe du monde
quelque part voilà tu entends passionné
il ya une certaine frange d'émotion
quand tu vois des moments comme ça mais
moi ma là je me tiens parce que je suis
avec toi et qu'on se connaît pas c'est
la première fois que je te rends compte
mais au moins quand je suis chez moi je
pleure devant mon écran mais je suis
aussi hystérique que les commentateurs
sportifs quand il ya un but et pas
forcément la coupe du monde par
forcément la france donc voilà on est de
rendre dans ces niveaux d'émotion et de
et qu'il a enfin c'est quand même un
exploit fouet puis même ces images vous
avez vu ces images
enfin quand le quand le premier étage se
détache et qui retombe sur terre et
qu'il arrive alors là on n'a pas vu
arriver en direct c'est un peu dommage
parce qu'on avait perdu le signal un
moment de la came revue les cantons noir
le retour du signal caméra et qu'on vous
ces morceaux de fusées kir de redessan
depuis l'espace qui est arrivé sur sa
barre dans l'atlantique donc et voilà
mes copines aux mille lacroix dit waow
et en plus pour ce vol historique c'est
quand même incroyable qui réussit cet
exploit encore enfin moi je m'en lasse
pas
pourtant des retours de deux fusées
comme ça sur terre j'en ai vu des
dizaines qui se passait bien je ne m'en
lasse pas c'est vraiment comme à de la
science fiction
il est 21 heures 37 à paris il était 15
heures 22 et 21 22 en france au moment
au centre spatial kennedy en floride et
bien cette fusée a décollé ce convoi 15
minutes après c'est que tout se passe
bien si vous nous rejoignez voilà on
voit ces images encore actuellement en
direct où les choses sont très très
positive
aucun incident particulier tout s'est
déroulé comme ça devait se passer si le
décollage a pu avoir lieu à 21h 22h
heure française
15h22 heure locale pourquoi justement se
poser cette question parce que mercredi
en raison des conditions météorologiques
le décollage avait été repoussé il a pu
avoir lieu et ensuite tout se passe bien
pour l'instant avec une phase critique
c'est ce que tu évoquais et quelques
années
la lutte qui elle aussi est passée là on
est sur une phase où le danger
j'imagine toujours mais beaucoup moins
important mais bien sûr il ya toujours
un danger l'espace c'est évidemment
dangereux mais mais la phase critique
est passé les astronautes sont en bonne
santé en sécurité dans leur vaisseau et
a priori le vaisseau va bien et il est
sur la bonne orbite
d'après ce que j'entends dans le dans le
retour mais peut-être que j'ai loupé une
information mais a priori tout à l'air
d'aller bien
donc là on va vraiment en direct des
images de notre planète
c'est bon en hd c'est tellement bien
c'est raide et le jeu et le et le soleil
pourvoi qui est blanc qui nous on voit
jaune mais c'est parce que l'atmosphère
lisons d'optique mais notre étoile et et
blanche
en fait et bien à ce qu'on voit en gros
c'est la planète est derrière moi c'est
ça voilà voilà donc ça c'est assez
impressionnant aussi comme image 5
lentement voit ça et pareil c'est un
spectacle dont je ne me lasse absolument
jamais est de savoir que là en plus il y
a deux astronautes à bord
c'est d'autant plus émouvant évidemment
est d'autant plus émouvant du fait que
ce soit le la première fois qu encore
une fois que ce soit un vaisseau
fabriquer conçu et fabriqué par une
entreprise privée
avec bien sûr de l'argent d'une agence
publique qui à la nasa et que ça
fonctionne jusqu'ici donc c'est là
jusque là c'est une totale réussite
et je voudrais juste avoir une pensée
pour thomas pesquet parce que d'après
mes informations j'ai parié à une
personne de son équipe ya quelques jours
il m'a dit qu'il y avait des très très
très fortes chances pour que thomas
pesquet pour sa mission de l'année
prochaine en 2021
ils partent avec un vaisseau space x
donc sur la suite pour thomas ps que la
whey ouais ouais donc ça c'est bientôt
en 2020 2021 alors je sais pas quand
exactement
mais c'est 2021 et a priori pas retiré
au conditionnel parce que se passe entre
censure il partirait avec un vaisseau
sky city
sinon ce sera boeing et puis voilà une
question qui se pose en ce sens pour
nous tous vous qui regardez ce live ce
soir c'est impossible bouffée d'oxygène
on sait que depuis quelques mois il ya
le confinement il ya la crise sanitaire
tout ça voilà on a réussi à garder les
maîtres des quarts qui sont
réglementaires mais il ya aussi cette
question c'est de se dire est ce qu'il
ya un impact aussi de ce côté là c'est
finalement le 3 mai puis se met en place
le décollage a eu lieu on rappelle qu
aux etats unis ils ont franchi il ya
quelques jours le cap des cent mille
victimes décédées du commun 19
il ya encore des états des villes où
un confinement ou en tout cas des
mesures assez stricte ça n'a pas eu
d'impact pour que ça puisse se faire
ça a eu d impact sur le reste mais je
crois que en fait le truc c'est que
quand on quand on décale dans le temps
des missions comme ça ça coûte des
millions de dollars donc en fait ils se
sont organisés pour que le vol est quand
même mieux malgré malgré la pandémie
voilà je pense que c'est vraiment la
motivation principale
mais encore une fois le nombre
d'employés à la nasa a été extrêmement
réduit
on l'a vu sur les images ce que moi j'ai
pas suivi le live aujourd'hui
malheureusement jeter dans le tgv y
avait pas de peu importe ma vie n'a
aucun intérêt mais on voyait que les
employés de gaza avec tous étaient tous
masqués que quand ils osent mosquée jim
bidzos stein donc et pdg et le directeur
d'un nasa actuels sont allés voir les
astronautes
ils étaient séparés par une barrière de
sécurité il avait démasqué les
astronautes bien sur son antenne ce qui
est toujours le cas mais mort quand
débit donc il ya vraiment que les
employés de la nasa qui était utile pour
que ce vol se passe est évidemment tout
et tout les tous les gestes barrière
toutes les collections tout le monde
fait un calcul ça va revenir on servait
dans un instant où ils ont débuté
[Musique]
c'est vrai que le coût de ce genre de
mission il est quand même extrêmement
important oui c'est l'image de times
square à new york toujours toujours
confiné pour l'instant c'est important
de dire oui savoir manier on va on va
partir dans l'espace pour l'instant il
fait un petit 2 1 petit point aux usa
tout quand ça se passe comment ça se
passe à new york mais on va repartir
dans l'espace vous inquiétez pas c'est
un petit détour
je pense qu'il ya pire comme endroit que
surtout qu'en plus on peut pas y aller
en ce moment donc ça permet de voyager
ont fait voyager en attendant c'était
une très belle image interview de
repartir dans les phrases
de toute façon le live on voit monsieur
en cravate par une collection moment où
on pourra la récupérer
non la nasa organisait un live sur
jusqu'à l'amarrage en fait jusqu'à
jusqu'à ce que les assauts autres
entrent dans la station spatiale
donc je crois qu'ils ont prévu 24 heures
le live 24 ans ouais bah c'est
historique un bon ils ont mis les moyens
à hauteur des caméras ou non il ya tour
est là on voit bien où vous voyez les
astronautes à l'intérieur évidemment
station spatiale internationale il ya
des caméras je sais pas si tu avais
suivi à l'arrivée de thomas pesquet dans
la station mais mais voilà il ya des
camarades dans le vaisseau est le cas
mais raté le cut à la trappe
donc oui oui y'a tout s'efface d'arrivée
et dont j -c ou oui parce qu'il ya un
risque de collision à une vitesse qui
n'est pas prévue avec la station
maintenant c'est automatique jusqu'ici
ça serait bien mais encore une fois là
c'est seulement la deuxième fois que
cette capsule va faire a rendez vous
avec la station puisqu'il ya eu un vol
de test donc à vide avec juste un
mannequin à l'intérieur automatique qui
s'est bien passé mais là c'est encore
automatique mais en cas de problème les
astronautes peuvent repasser en manuel
donc a priori c'est moins risqué puisque
il ya des gens à l'intérieur pour
attraper le concile problème est
vraiment en cas de problème
bah c'est pas grave les astronautes
redescendront sur terre sans s'être
amarrée à la station et la mission sera
perdu mais question qui se pose c'est
comment tu fais là c'est quand même
comme c'est un vol de démonstration
ils resteront moins longtemps dans la
station normalement l'émission ces six
mois thomas pesquet par six mois une
halle c'est mission de six mois mais là
ils partent que deux mois c'est un vol
de démonstration mais à l'intérieur de
la station c'est une mission classique
donc c'est à dire qu'ils vont faire des
expériences scientifiques dans la
station spatiale
ils vont la réparer c'est de l'entretien
de la station c'est mais c'est une
mission classique d'entretien de
stations d'expériences scientifiques
elle sera juste un peu plus la jauge ici
une séquence de communication à c'est un
peu la fierté de la nasa pour aix -
ouais c'est
ça se passe bien donc ils sont contents
après j'arrive pas à vraiment suivre à
ce qu'ils disent bien sûr c'est
compliqué de parler de tes coûté 320
c'est encore plus dur que des crues mais
maintenant mais en gros ils sont très
contents
jusqu'ici tout se passe bien le le
premier étage a été récupéré
donc c'est cool parce qu'il va pouvoir
être là utilisées pour un autre vol
les astronautes sont sains et saufs ils
ont l'air d'être sur la bonne
trajectoire
jusqu'ici c'était un sans-faute en tout
cas d'après les sourires que je vois
bien alors on va voir héros pour ces
dernières minutes là si éventuellement
les gens que les questions dans les
commentaires on va essayer dé prendre
plan s'essaiera et d'y répondre donc
n'hésitez pas à réagir dans les
commentaires
voilà youtube facebook on est on est en
live sur les deux plateformes on vous
remercie d'ailleurs d'être d'être aussi
nombreux à me suivent depuis depuis tout
à l'heure
donc ce décollage on est à + 23 minutes
que des collages donc pour ceux qui
viennent de nous rejoindre à 21h45 heure
de paris leur local bah y'en a plus
parce qu'ils vont quitter son voile sont
en dehors des alors si ils ont quand
même une heure pas d'user dans la
station spatiale internationale il ya
une heure vingt seller which hockey
parce qu'en fait comme la station
spatiale comme son nom l'indiqué et
internationale elle est gérée par
plusieurs équipes
en fait elle est gérée par bas par les
américains par les russes par les
européens par les japonais
il ya déjà connaît donc comme il ya
plusieurs nationalités à bord il faut
bien choisir une 1h est en fait le
méridien de greenwich il est il est
pratique parce qu'il est pile entre les
etats-unis la russie donc du goût bas
c'est un petit peu un couac apparent
deux comme ça voilà personne n'est lésé
et eller dans la station seller de
l'autre alors elle va pas mais alors pas
mal de questions et commentaires
quoique si on parle dans quel est le but
de ce beau spectacle s'il vous plaît
nous dit l'aurore bas c'est ce qu'on
disait au début c'est à dire que là
l'objectif c'était que les américains
reprennent une indépendance par rapport
aux russes sur la possibilité et la
faisabilité d'envoyer des astronautes
dans l'espace
donc désormais il en à la fois une fusée
qui fonctionne une capsule qui a l'air
de très bien fonctionner et voilà donc
donc ils peuvent à nouveau renvoyer des
astronautes les leurs
mais aussi des astronautes d'autres
nationalités à l'avenir comme thomas
pesquet depuis le sol américain
donc ils ne sont plus dépendants des
russes pour envoyer leurs propres
américain dans l'espace et en même temps
effectivement cette île sous traitent en
gros l'envoi de l'américain dans
l'espace puisque c'est pas la nasa qui a
développé cette fusée est ce vaisseau c
est une entreprise privée qui a répondu
à l'appel d'offres et qui a respecté le
cahier des charges très strict de la
nasa
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la seule
entreprise puisque boeing aussi à des
blocs quelque chose question de hilla
dans les commentaires j'avoue le coût de
la mission lorsqu'on un chiffre
approximatif pas ce qu'est ce qui les
communique officiellement non il est pas
communiqué officiellement
ça tourne alors en fait c'est pas tant
le coût de la mission que là on va
parler du coût du vol donc du lancement
c'est autour de 50 60 millions de
dollars sachant que la nasa jusqu'ici
ces neuf dernières années
acheté à l' agence spatiale russe le
prix d'un siège dans dans la fusée
soyouz dans un vaisseau soyouz
les derniers prix c'était 86 millions de
dollars donc ils font un petit peu des
économies quant à moi aussi donc ça
coûte moins cher un shoot est en avance
par les deux elon musk
oui voilà parce que c'est l'homme qui
est un peu d'ailleurs tout ça
complètement qui est il
quel est son intérêt aussi derrière tout
ça parce que ça avec certaines personnes
sont là dans les commentaires à se dire
mais pourquoi dépenser autant d'argent
est ce qu'il ya un intérêt derrière
commercial personnel
voilà alors en fait ilan est donc c'est
il est né en avant en dessous et on
l'affaiblît les et en afrique du sud
en 1961 mais oui oui les sud africains
d'origine bon maintenant il a la
nationalité américaine mais c'est un
entrepreneur en fait c'est alors je le
fais très rapidement mais c'est en gros
c'est lui qui a fondé à paypal alors
qu'on connaît tous
il l'a revendue il n'a pas commencé par
paypal mais vraiment je la fêterais très
courte il est devenu milliardaire est en
fait lui son rêve depuis tout petit
c'est l'espace quoi mais comme jeff
bezos au sein d'amazon c'est pour ça que
tous ces géants du web ils injectent
leur argent dans le spatial c'est parce
que c'est leur rêve de gosse et donc
et donc ils donnent losc a fondé space x
donc est il arrivé un jour parmi les
grands pontes du spatial il avait encore
fait décoller aucune fusée space x avait
seulement quelques années il avait
accepté tous ces trucs et mais il est
arrivé il a dit à tous les pontes du
spatial genre arianespace les américains
poussent à je m'appelle in metz et dans
5 ans vous êtes tous morts et évidemment
ça fait ricaner tout le monde sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ça me fait plus rire
personne
ils sont pas tous morts autour mais bon
il a avancé très très vite donc lui il à
développer des lanceurs donc des fusées
donc s'appelle les falcons qui
fonctionne très très bien et donc c'est
le premier à avoir fabriqué une fusée
qui revient sur terre et qui est
réutilisé donc il a complètement
bouleversé l'industrie du spatial
vraiment personne ne fait ça au monde a
parlé donc la bouleverser le spatial
mais il a pu le faire grâce à l'argent
de la nasa qui vient donc de cet appel
d'offres qui se compte en milliards
quand ces 4 milliards soit si le contrat
à 4 milliards à vérifier le chiffre mais
c'est à peu près ça pour développer
justement donc une capsule habitée pour
envoyer des astronautes et le lanceur
qui va avec
donc évidemment que sans l'argent de la
nasa pour développer tout ça il aurait
pas pu faire ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à
présent
donc c'est une entreprise qui est oui
mais il ya quand même beaucoup de
beaucoup d'argent public
où allons-nous moss ché pa n'a plus rien
mais on peut même avoir leur au
décollage ou un truc temps c'est
compliqué s'est passée cette éprouvante
runnymede parce qu'en fait on a pu le
retour de ce qui se passe là bas on va
rester juste quelques minutes avec vous
pour répondre à quelques unes de vos
questions
parce que chez nous alors on est on est
toujours là bien sûr les gens nous
regardent et nous y sommes encore
nombreux à être là alors que c'est juste
plus que nous d'eux voilà la partie
depuis ça fait quoi maintenant ça fait
28 minutes maintenant
alors si vous nous rejoignez justement
c'est à dire que tout s'est bien passé
elle a décollé mais pour rebondir juste
en soit les masques lui son rêve quoi
c'est d'y aller lui-même de mettre en
place des halles en lui son rêve c'est
cissé mars
c'est lui alors qu'ingrid et il fait
toujours des annonces as et
grandiloquence arrivant on peut lui
faire confiance sur le fait qu'il va
faire ce qui dit qu'il va faire parce
que jusqu'ici il l'a fait faut juste pas
lui faire confiance sur le planning bien
son projet le graal c'est quoi
ccc de coloniser mars c'est de fonder
une ville se remarque à quel horizon 10
de ce que c'était mais c'est
complètement farfelu c'est 2030 2040
ça n'a aucun sens les français mais ça
n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens mais
justement ce qui a explosé hier le sm4
qui n'a rien à voir avec la fusée
d'aujourd'hui la capsule d'aujourd'hui
mais ce qui est exposé hier c'est un
autre programme que space x développe
justement c'est avec ce prototype de
dessau qu'il veut faire des plus grosses
missions vers la lune et bernard ce donc
c'est en cours ça c'est en cours c'est
juste pas au courant et que ce n'était
pas la paix payeurs mais rien de grave
c'est normal dans le spatial tout le
monde pc était truc lahmada aussi au
début et la russie pareil et la chine
pareil bon mais voilà donc lui son
ultime c'est mars et ça avance mais pas
dans les délais qu'il donne la france
dans tout ça est que si on est venu dans
les commentaires alors la france
la france fait partie de l'agencé
spatiale européenne ça n'a pas vraiment
de sens de parler vraiment de la france
maintenant on fait partie de l' agence
spatiale européenne l'agencé spatiale
européenne pas vraiment enfin en fait
une question de politique de choix
politiques
on n'a pas vraiment envie d'être
indépendant dans le fait d'envoyer des
gens dans l'espace ça coûte très cher et
puis et qui on est plutôt dans une danse
dans un esprit de collaboration et de
partenariat donc partenariat avec la
russie jusqu'ici partenariat avec les
américains puisque thomas pesquet va
sûrement partir avec les américains
voient là et que les astronautes
français sont déjà partis dans des
navettes spatiales
donc on fait des partenariats pourquoi
pas avec la chine puisqu'il ya deux
astronautes européens qui s'entraîne
avec des astronautes chinois en ce
moment donc voilà on en esprit de
partenariat de collaboration mais on a
pas du tout de volonté politique de
d'être indépendant en termes de vols
habités
habiter c'est avec des gens dedans par
contre on a les meilleurs lanceurs au
monde avec ariane des coraux en duel je
pense que c'est ça non enola la base
spatiale effectivement de guyane il
s'appelle le centre spatial guyanais qui
se trouve à kourou qui est géré
conjointement par le cnes donc l' agence
spatiale française est aussi un petit
peu par les russes parce qu'il ya des
lanceurs russes aussi par mon bref c'est
un peu con
sam et mais voilà on a une base spatiale
à kourou d'où on envoie toutes nos
fusées ariane qui sont les meilleurs
lanceurs au moins en termes de vols de
fer d'envoi de satellites mais encore
une fois on parle pas de vol habité chez
les gens qui ont regardé je suis entre
manga et sur téléphone ici les nombreux
commentaires comme était à ya plein de
petits coeurs et petit pouce bleus c'est
très sympathique comme mission oui sont
là ils sont nombreux je pense qu'ils
sont contents parce que ça s'est bien
passé
il ya toujours le le risque la crainte
mais il y avait les excitations aussi
que voilà de vivre un moment aussi
stoïque et ces images ces images
tellement folle pain de lanceurs qui
revient de terre qu'on voit depuis
l'espace
avec une si belle qualité d'image c'est
assez magique à quand un voeu qui
décolle de biens non pas juste on risque
à des trucs prévu justement dans l'est
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois alors je vais taper mes
énergies à la question c'est quoi les
prochaines j'essayais échéance que ce
soit même babolat on a vécu un très beau
moment ce soir et ce qui en a d'autre de
prévu et ce qu il yad autres
d'autres projets là qui sont proches
d'aboutir et qui vont nous permettre de
voyager à nouveau oui alors évidemment
des tirs de fusées il y en a plusieurs
par mois que ce soit depuis san
américain depuis la chine depuis la
guyane
voilà des lancements en a plusieurs par
mois il ya une appli via des
applications qui voulaient liste tous
mais c'est souvent des satellites des
satellites soit d'observation de la
terre soit militaire soit pour avoir
deux gps google vidéo enfin voila si des
satellites c'est rarement des des vols
habités on a un ou deux par an mais il
ya aussi toutes les missions
d'exploration scientifique vers les
autres planètes et ça c'est super
excitant
et justement cette année c'est une année
martienne c'est à dire qu'en fait pour
aller vers mars pour envoyer des
missions vers mars
il faut attendre que la terre et mars
soit au plus problème n'est l'autre à
peu près donc ça ça arrive tous les 26
mois donc à peu près tous les deux ans
on a une fenêtre de tir vers mars de
quelques semaines et donc il trouve que
cette année il ya trois missions qui
vont partir vers mars
une mission américaine qui parle en
quelques semaines est d'ailleurs juste à
côté de la fusée qui vient de décoller
il y avait une autre fusée qui s'appelle
atlas et qui est prête pour envoyer le
nouveau rover américains s'appellent
persévérance qui est donc la petite
soeur de curiosity qui actuellement sur
mars depuis qu'elle regardait beaucoup
d'attention ce soir parce que c'est son
destin dans quelques temps c'est
demain ça elle partira en juillet
persévérance et elle a même un petit et
un petit drone un petit un petit drone à
bord donc il y aura bientôt un drone sur
mars
par contre le voyage c'est long c'est
entre ce sera huit mois de voyage ça
atterrira sur mars en 2022
mais elles partiront dans quelques
semaines et il ya aussi à robert chinois
qui partira vers mars cette année est
également alors je sais plus je crois
que c'est les indiens qui envoie aussi
un satellite autour de mars
s'il ne dit pas de bêtise et il y avait
la mission européenne qui s'appelle
exomars avec le rover rosalind franklin
qui devait partir cette année mais qui
au dernier test s'était pas concluant au
niveau des parachutes
donc ils ont préféré jouer la sécurité
refaire déteste être sûr que tout
fonctionne bien et donc la prochaine
fenêtre
ce sera en 2020 en 2022 donc donc aux
amis franklyn le rover européens vers
mars partira en 2011 et les gens qui a
posé la question sur les lézards les
applications qu'il a pu évoquer durant
ce direct parce que certains noms
peuvent le temps noté on va vous repas
et justement ces habitations
vous voulez vous fait alors moi ce que
j'utilise donc pour l'igas alors j'ai un
iphone je connais pas exactement les
noms des applications pour android et
pour les autres mais ça c'est peut-être
que certaines reviennent sur wells fargo
mais je trouve très facilement et
effectivement peut-être un accent
compatibles alors pour l' iss pour voir
pour savoir quand vous pouvez voir lier
cet ancien ça dans le ciel à l'oeil nu
iss potter je te montre je vous parle
cet hommage
voilà je sais pas si vous verrez bien
ces voix là oui le buzz on m'avait voilà
hop voilà iss spectateurs voilà et pour
tous les vols cd gratuite selon elle est
gratuite
et bien sûr toutes les applications que
dont je vais donner mon sont gratuites
pour tous tous les toutes les fusées qui
décolle quelles que soient les le pays
où le satellite ya dedans ça s'appelle
space next space flight tout attaché
voilà et à l'intérieur ça ressemble à ça
donc là on allait les deux les deux vols
qui viennent de ce hamas je ne sais pas
bon bref ça s'appelle mext space flight
la tâche et on mettra peut-être des
lions et
en plus les horaires sont en horaire
français par heure de paris france
métropolitaine donc ça c'est cool
et puis si vous avez envie de voir le
ciel mais que vous voyez je ne savais
pas exactement ce que vous regardez il
ya une application qui est très bien qui
s'appelle star walk deux pareils et
gratuite
et donc il suffit de mettre son son
téléphone comme ça et donc ça se
géolocalise et on voit dans le téléphone
exactement ce qu'on voit derrière le
téléphone donc s'il y a une étoile ou un
truc très brillante que vous voyez et
voulait savoir ce que c'est voilà
l'application vous indiquera bah voila
tu sais c'est une étoile elle s'appelle
comme ça ou alors c'est une planète
parce qu'en ce moment on voit très bien
venus depuis quelques mois les toiles
qui n'est pas une étoile mais le point
très très brillant qu'on voit arriver
dès que la nuit commence à tomber dans
le ciel partout c'est pas une étoile
c'est une planète c'est vénus donc voilà
ça vous permettra de savoir qu'on peut
regarder dans le ciel quand et est comme
un enfant regarder vos commentaires
voilà la justice y en a beaucoup qui
disent à quel heure ça décolle ça a déjà
décollé c'était à 21h22 c'était donc il
ya 37 minutes maintenant
or locales s'étaient 15h22 donc et 15h59
maintenant et c'était au centre spatial
kennedy en floride
donc on peut bien être un peu résumé
l'effet de cette soirée ceux qui
viennent de nous rejoindre c'est que les
choses se sont bien passées peut-être
revenir sur les étapes de ce qu'on a
vécu ce soir ou bien sûr alors à 21h22
effectivement la fusée falcon 9 a
décollé avec la capsule crew dragonne
des space x tout en haut de la fusée et
quelques minutes après le décollage le
premier étage donc le plus gros de la
fusée s'est détachée du deuxième étage
qui poussait encore un petit peu la
capsule ont respecté la fin a encore
accéléré et donc le premier acteur étage
de 10 est retombé sur terre alors que le
territoire est encore limitée
la plus grosse partie de la rue valmont
justement à quoi au juste à essayer tape
sur l 1 il est exceptionnel de la place
de paris c'est devenu un très grand
réalisateur parce que je voulais pas en
parler c'est lui qui réalise les live
quand on fait des interviews et logo est
touché c'est lui qu'elle a relevé yard
traiter qu'avec lui ils sont ils sont
sur un ordi depuis tout à l'heure et il
s'offre une réalisation digne du passage
à l'an 2000 exceptionnel et du coup bah
merci à eux parce que là ils nous
permettent de revoir justement parce
qu'ils viennent de nous rejoindre je
pense que c'est suffisant mais c'est
fabuleux
c'est la rue fernand est vraiment tu
veux me faire un travail et une deuxième
fois la vraiment dit cela ça permet
d'avoir des images profond cela que nous
rejoindre et c'est super donc voilà
d'expliquer qu'à l'intervalle mais ça
s'est bien passé et l'accélération le
kilométrage en bas à gauche juste à côté
à droite
le chiffre pourrait monter 6,2 trois
cases c'est l'altitude et l'altitude en
kilomètres et donc la voilà cette phase
jeu là se repentent juste dans ses
explications au moment où glabre et là
c'est la phase critique parce que c'est
la phase de l'accélération et la plus
importante et donc et donc où le lanceur
à un maximum de pression partout sur lui
quand je lis lanceur s'est aussi refusée
c'est exactement le même
c'est la même chose c'est juste deux
mots différents pour la même chose une
fusée ça sert à lancer des trucs là en
l'occurrence à une capsule avec des gens
dedans donc c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
ça
donc voilà donc là c'est vraiment la
phase critique et comme je disais tout à
l'heure on a l'impression qu'elle va de
plus en plus à l'horizontale mais en
fait elles montrent toujours c'est juste
qu'elle suit la courbe de la terre parce
que la terre est ronde et non pas plate
et donc elle suit la courbe de la terre
et c'est pour ça qu'on a l'impression
qu'elle va qu'elle va de plus en plus à
l'horizon temps mais la phase aller
droite on souhaite enfin les droites non
parce qu'elle suit la courbe de la terre
alors ok en fait nous on la voit
vraiment on la voit vraiment aller à
l'horizontale et c'est en fait la vision
c'est comme si c'était un avion passe
comme ça mais à la façon de se déplacer
c'est alors que c'est pas tout à fait ça
alors qu'elle monte encore en altitude
et on le voit avec
l'altitude tu vois 42 km 43 km vraiment
c'est donc là ils sont quasiment à mi
chemin vers l'espace puisque aux 50 km
et là on va voir le moment alors pas
encore mais on commence à voir sur
l'écran de gauche par la terre puisqu'on
voit déjà la courbure sur le côté droit
de l'écran de gauche on voit que voilà
l'affairé courbes et qu'elle est très
belle qui a des nuages en dessous et si
la floride est donc là on passe sur la
caméra intérieure donc qui est au niveau
du deuxième étage qui va rester a poussé
la capsule à des astronautes
avant qu'elle se détache là en fait là
là on voit on voit le premier étage
s'est détaché et là il va retomber sur
terre
littéralement il remet ça et ça j'ai
vraiment senti un engouement très
important pour toi à ce moment là bas
mais que sait il ya une prouesse
technique quelque part sur ce moment là
oui parce que jusqu'ici dans l'histoire
du spatial
l'histoire du spatial à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un vol de fusées à chacun
une fusée décoller avec quelque chose à
l'intérieur pressoir un satellite un
rover ou des gens la fusée ensuite été
perdu quand c'est bien c'est à dire que
elle retombe dans l'océan
c'est pour ça qu'on a encore des
morceaux de fusées qui envoyait vers
l'ol les hommes vers la lune au fond de
l'atlantique
ou alors les petits morceaux qui détache
au fur et à mesure brûlant l'atmosphère
mais là ces fusées donc reviennent sur
terre en un seul morceau deux bouts que
ce soit sur un pas de tir ou sur une
barque dans l'atlantique en fonction du
vol et est ensuite sont réutilisés pour
d'autres wolf et ça avance paye 6
personne ne l'avait fait et c'est ça
reste des images qui sont dignes de
science fiction parce que revoir ses
fusées qui reviennent à la verticale
voilà et moi ce que je vous conseille de
faire les amis qui m'écoutait c'est
d'aller voir sur la chaîne de space x
ils ont fait un medley enfin une
compilation de tous les retours de fuser
sur terre mais qui se sont mal passées
au début parce que ils ont pas réussi du
premier coup a récupéré les fusées au
début ça arrivait à côté de la barre
donc l'atlantique
ensuite ça arrivait sur la barre je mets
ça explosait ensuite ça arrivait sur la
barge mai
ça tombait bien et donc ils ont fait une
compilation de tout
toutes les fois où ça a pété ou alors
que ça tombait vraiment qu'elle peut
mettre de la barge dommage et c'est une
petite musique genre avec en bas voici
comment ne pas faire atterrir une chute
avec beaucoup d'humour en plus donc
voila et à chaque fois vous voyez ça en
direct
ils nous ont rien cacher des échecs
parce que sur les dix dernières enfin
sur les dernières décennies de 3d un
essai mais on a eu aussi les drames avec
un salaire sont venus trois colombiens
ont absolument vous avez 2000 où il y
avait plusieurs victimes
ouais alors là on parle vraiment quand
je dis que ça pète et que c'est rigolo
c'est de tracer sa route personne à
l'intérieur
la conséquence c'est que les moteurs y
avoir détaché c'est vraiment d'une fusée
voilà ce qu'on voit sur l'écran de
droite donc c'est la physique qui
revient avec une caméra qui est dessus
et qui donc qui retombe sur où là aussi
un problème il a pas de risque humain
voilà non c'est vraiment important de
chou fiches de recettes et louis devaux
et on a eu des abus des drames
alors il faut savoir que personne n'est
mort en l'espace jamais rien
personnellement dans l'espoir fait
intéressant les deux accidents de
navette spatiale qui a vu parce qu'il ya
eu d'autres accidents avaient spécial
mais les navettes spatiales américaines
et effectivement deux accidents le
premier dans les années 80 et j'ai pu
les attentes à 7 86 et le dernier
c'était dans les années 10 mai tous les
battus désolé je sais plus chaud ce soir
2008 victime en 2003 donc c'était 86 et
2003 et effectivement la première enfin
il y avait un des drames c'était quand
ils sont revenus sur terre et donc
c'était dans l'atmosphère dont il
n'était plus en espace et un autre drame
c'est que tu cites est le premier ou le
deuxième mais c'était au moment du
décollage qui s'était pas encore dans
l'espace
c'est pour ça que je disais j'ai
vraiment insister sur la sur l'aspect
critique premières minutes
parce qu'en fait une faute et dans
l'espace il ya plus d'air il ya plus de
frictions il ya il ya du danger bien sûr
mais c'est pas le même danger est de
quasiment rien arrivé c'est en fait
c'est comme les avions les moments
critiques si le décollage et
l'atterrissage
donc là c'est le retour quand on est en
vol c'est assez rare qui se passe des
choses et donc là c'est pareil c'est au
décollage et à l'atterrissage s'est
l'axema
les engins en fait ont les plus grosses
pressions les plus fins c'est là que les
angevins sont vraiment les plus
fortement traumatisée mais c'est là
qu'il peut se passer des choses
yann dans les commentaires qui aborde
une question avec humour mais qui est
comme intéressante c'est le côté
l'écologie nous dit c'est qu'elle
vignette critères tout ça on une fusée
parce que oui ça ça voilà on voit toute
cette fumée tout à ces flammes et où on
se dit que c'est quand même là dans
cette fusée la quillane décollé sans
oublier mais le reste du carburant et de
l'oxygène liquide
si j'étais oxygène voilà c'est pas ça le
respire c'est ce n'est pas sale donc
voilà maintenant ses lanceurs space x
comme je réponds depuis tout à l'heure
ils reviennent donc c'est non réutilisés
donc c'est vachement plus écolo même si
là par contre ça c'est la partie la plus
critique cela quand on voit la scène
kérosène qui est oui oui là c'est la
partie un peu plus dur j'ai eu des
chiffres mais restait des tonnes c'est
vrai on n'imagine pas ce que pour
pousser comme ça on voit encore un
trajet qui est monté jusqu'à 27 millions
oui 27 min km heure donc oui il faut pas
mal de tonnes de carburant voilà donc
encore une fois ces lanceurs là sont
réutilisables donc on est mieux que
toutes les fusées qu'on lance par
ailleurs et qui sont qui ne fonctionne
qu'une fois qu'ils voient là c'est à
usage unique malheureusement et elle
retombe dans les dans l'océan ou cramant
atmosphère mais crown prospère du coup
c'est pas grave parce que vraiment tout
est brûlé donc il n'y a rien mais voilà
pour les gros morceau qui retombe dans
l'océan c'est un peu un peu dommage
maintenant on parle de quelques
lancements par mois à l'échelle mondiale
par mois par mois ça peut paraître
beaucoup mais effectivement en termes de
pollution
enfin ça c'est même pas comparable par
rapport au trafic aérien
alors évidemment hors pandémie ou au
trafic routier ou même au trafic navale
c'est vraiment cette saison ça n'a aucun
sens et lui dire c'est ça par rapport à
toute la caisse france est vraiment bien
maintenant effectivement la question se
pose c'est intéressant et si je peux me
permettre de faire de parler des choses
que je fais par ailleurs sur d'autres
plateformes
mais j'avais parlé un petit peu de paul
ii alors j'avais fait une vidéo pour les
débris spatiaux sur la chaîne string
theory
voilà il évoque effectivement ce
problème de alors les débris spatiaux
c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya dans l'espace
mais je parle un petit peu de pollution
générale de des lanceurs des fusées et
c'est donc j'aborde ce sujet dans une
vidéo qui seront sur scène théories sur
les débris spatiaux en garde à la
conclusion pour tous ceux qui justement
va le retrouver étaient différents
travaux ou pour trouver sur internet et
certains on n'a pas la langue dans
quelques petits instants mais on parlait
de goya quelqu'un qui va être grenoble
dans les commentaires c'est vrai qu'on a
parlé de paris tout à l'heure pour la
possibilité de le voir ce soir c'était à
23h12 donnera un trader dans une heure
et trois minutes on en sera même temps
toute la france
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on vous quittera
dans pas longtemps parce que l'idée
c'est qu'on puisse y avoir une fois que
le ciel est dégagé ce ne sont pas les
noms de villes en france
je crois du coup vous pourrez voir ça et
bien on peut pas le voir à l'oeil nu si
c'est compliqué à la station alors c'est
la station qui passe à voir 3h12 sa
mission spatiale c'est parce que l'on
sait neto le filon tu sais quoi c'est
ouais alors non pas dans le dos rond
point tri devoir voir effectivement
c'est un très très gros point brillant
très très brillant donc plus brillants
qu'une étoile quasiment aussi je crois
que c'est à peu près la même luminosité
que venus en ce moment croît de près nos
plus brillants et donkey parce qu'ils
quitteraient re spéciale en quatre
minutes vous pouvez pas la louper elles
arrivent de l'ouest elle repart vers
l'est alors plus ou moins leur sud mais
en gros c'est toujours d'ouest en est et
qu on la détecte pas pourtant tu vois là
je vais sortir je m comme cela je vais
regarder passer la loi parce que tu ne
sais pas que tu vois qu'elle mais il n'y
a qu'une seule chose qui soit aussi
brillante et qu'il a il d'ouest en est
en d'aussi rapidement donc il n'y a rien
d'autre
voilà donc 23h12 soyez prêts regarder ça
se passe très vite sa durée auquel
facebook oui elles traversent le ciel
enquête mais c'est tous les soirs pas
tous les soirs parce que la station
spatiale ont calé en orbite autour de la
terre et son orbite se décale un petit
peu à chaque fois donc en ce moment on a
la chance de l'avoir
le soir voilà mais voilà des fois elle
se décale ou alors trois mois ce soir
c'est un coup parce qu'elle pourrait
très bien pendant quelques semaines
quoiqu'elle ne survole pas la france n'a
pas le soir la survole en journée mais
ans
on est on voit pas les défauts le tour
de la terre en fête ont elles fait le
tour de la terre en 1h15
oui en fait c'est pour ça que les
astronautes de la terre et ses 27 milles
c'est grâce justement on fait qu'il ya
plus l'atmosphère c'est ça qu'il a
exactement elle est poussée comment il
ya toujours du parce que je dirais peut
pas être rechargée ou non alors elle a
alors grimpé doucement pour tourner
comme ça je veux dire à la rentrée quand
il ya des camps les astronautes yvon il
est bon en vaisseau donc se voit le
soyouz russes ou la lacrouts drag'on en
ce moment qui va y arriver à mike 1
ensuite ces vaisseaux samara la station
samares et sceller son des moteurs et de
temps en temps les moteurs des vaisseaux
qui sont amarrés à la station sont
allumés pour l'art et au cdh ont voulu
faire gagner un petit peu de vitesse
parce que elle freine quand même qu est
ce qu elle est à 400 km c'est l'espace
mais il ya quand même un peu de résidus
d'atmosphère et résidus mais ça a suffi
pour la freiner légèrement
il faut pas qu'elle prenne trop parce
que si elle freine trop elle tombe elle
retombe trop tendre donc il faut
l'accélérer de temps en temps et donc
donner des petits coups de moteurs des
vaisseaux qui sont amarrés pour la et
pour éviter les débris spatiaux aussi
des fois il faut l'accélérer pour
qu'elle monte un petit peu en anglais ce
que la durée de vie je pense qu'elle va
revenir sur terre au moment où est-ce
que alors ça fait 20 ans qu'elle invite
sa fait 20ans voilà les premiers mots
durs parce qu'on l'a pas envoyé comme ça
d'un seul bloc a cédé modules qui sont
en fait c'est un jeu de lego qui se
réactualise le tendon est ce qu'on en
voit des nouveaux trucs l'écologie
évolué en battant on envoie des nouveaux
modules etc
mais il y en a pas qui redescendent que
ça ne peut que grossière donc à maurice
à devenir une ville oui c'est pas le but
mais c'est quand même au long des 5 mais
c'est quand même bon donc il ya des
modules qui ont été envoyés au fur et à
mesure qu'ils ont été collés les uns aux
autres vraiment comme un jeu de lego
avec les personnels ensuite est donc là
elle est assez grande mais alors je
crois que les budgets ont été votés pour
qu'elle fonctionne encore jusqu'en 2030
donc encore dix ans et après elle va
faire comme la station mir
donc soit on va la garder mais pourquoi
mais plutôt mais bon
via un moment et donc potentiellement
dangereuse par la sécurité sera pas
optimale donc a priori on va faire comme
la sat souvenir on va là redescendre et
à l'écrin bras dans l'atmosphère on vers
une autre après autre chose voilà autre
chose en fait là l'étape suivante c'est
une station spatiale en orbite autour de
la ville c'est un programme qui est
signée car hambourg l'europe participe
donc l'étape suivante temps dans
l'exploration habitée donc encore une
fois avec des gens à l'intérieur
ce sera une station plus petit coin
station spatiale mais en orbite autour
de l'accueil des cônes personnes à bord
dont ceux là en ce moment il ya trois
personnes
voilà ça fait un petit peu plus de vie à
l'intérieur et ils font quoi on peut
leur journée enfin c'est simple la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est là
ils vont arriver il faut arriver bientôt
il faut faire quoi exactement alors ils
ont un emploi du temps mais est acculé à
la seconde près même pas idée de l'heure
pas du temps de fou qui n'ont pas ce que
donc la saison passée l'international
c'est un laboratoire de recherche
sarrassat c'est la recherche
scientifique et donc si vous avez sud
là la mission de thomas pesquet il s'est
entraîné pendant des années pour faire
des manipulations des expériences
scientifiques etc et donc ils avaient un
emploi du temps bien calibré pour que va
de telle heure à telle heure ce soit l
expérience et l heure à telle heure
c'était l'expérience
ensuite il doit sortir dans l'espace
parce que ben il faut faire des
réparations sans pression extérieure
vous remplacez une batterie en panneaux
solaires resserré un moule ont installé
une expérience scientifique à
l'extérieur de la station et c'est donc
en fait il ya à la fois les expériences
scientifiques
que font les astronautes qui sont venus
à bord voilà et l'entretien de la
station de l'intérieur donc le ménage
comme thomas pesquet est arrivé il n'y a
pas eu de bol mais les toilettes sont
tombés en panne ont clôturé il ya tout
ce qui est entretient la station à
l'extérieur et donc implique des sorties
extravéhiculaires des sorties et que
l'on peut lire leurs travaux ce qu'on
peut voir ce qu'ils font à l'intérieur
est ce qu'on a en retour je suis pas là
par exemple en ce moment on parle tous
deux avec l'épidémie de kobe de 19 des
des travaux des scientifiques quand ils
mènent des expériences aux autres là ils
mènent des expériences à l'intérieur et
qunu grand public on peut les consulter
aussi comme ces études scientifiques de
médecins à la route comme toutes les
exclues les dix et il commence à sentir
comme toutes les études scientifiques
bien sûr il faut récupérer les données
il faut les exploiter les interpréter et
ensuite des publications scientifiques
qui sont publiés dans des revues de
relecture par les pairs donc c'est c'est
la démarche normale de la science sauf
que les expériences se font pas
s'enfermer dans l'espace mais sinon
c'est exactement bolloré ou sur ensuite
seront alors banon ce bassin dans les
revues un night shop dans les jambes a
en fait ça dépend parce que des
expériences dans des tas de domaines
donc ça peut être la médecine la
biologie physique
de quoi en fait donc donc tout dépend
c'est en tout cas c'est des revues
scientifiques
maintenant après il ya tous les
journalistes scientifiques qui sont là
pour vulgariser les publications qui
sortent et je crois qu'on a pas mal de
retours d expérience quand le café
thomas pesquet puisque c'est notre
astronautes c'est plus facile d'avoir du
coût des nouvelles puisqu'il vous en
donne de temps en temps mais mais voilà
c'est sélestat sciences tech celle qui
dit 23h12 processus 23h16 pour la
capsule c'est moi c'est ça c'est ça
donc les deux on a les deux ont pas en
capitaux mais encore une fois je suis
pas sûr que la capsule l'on puisse la
voir à l'oeil nu je pense qu'elle est
pas assez lumineuse et on a ce qu'il
faut mais ces défauts des jumelles il
faut je pense qu'il faut des bonnes
jumelles ou amédée pas celle qu'on a
chez nous pour autant de mails
d'observation alors que vous pouvez ici
un oui oui avec le zone de mon iphone
c'est mort
sinon je pense pas compliqué voilà il
faut un petit peu de matériel quand même
c'était important de la jumelle et jumet
pour garder les oiseaux et je pensais
peut-être un peu pour pour conclure un
peu tout ça le sentiment qu'il tient par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a vécu la voilà
prête à accepter les pas mal d'émotion
je sais vu me
si beaucoup parlé mais c'est super voilà
le ressenti un peu de cette soirée on
rappelle en 22h16 c'était à 21h 22h
alors française et à 15 heures 22 heures
locales le décollage a bien eu lieu il
s'est bien passé si vous ne jouez sur
brut sur l'ensemble de nos supports en
facebook live et sur youtube on salue
l'ensemble des personnes qui nous ont
suivis ça s'est bien passé et vous
l'avez vu les images que vous voyez
actuellement la ce que vous voyez c'est
en replay c'est ce qui s'est passé donc
il ya exactement cinquante cinq minutes
et on l'a vécu ensemble en direct sur
brut voilà les mots chemin que tu as pu
vivre à ce moment là bas alors je
t'avoue il croyait pas une seule seconde
parce que dans le tgv qui m'a amené chez
brute
il y avait encore 50% de risque que la
fusée partent pas ça va encore perdre ce
soir c'est parti j'avais une surprise
pour moi a ce prix je croyais pas donc
j'ai réalisé une bonne nouvelle et une
bonne surprise et le fait que tout se
soit passé nominalement pas nominalement
servir normalement projet spatial que
tout se soit bien passé vraiment dans
les conditions idéales c'est à dire que
le lanceur a bien fonctionné la capsule
visiblement fonctionne bien les
astronautes sont sains et saufs
et en plus ils ont récupéré le premier
étage sur la barge dans l'atlantique qui
toujours la cerise sur le gâteau et qui
est rapidement un exploit exceptionnel
donc moi je suis ravi maintenant ce
n'est pas fini il faut encore qu'ils
s'amarrer à la station et ça sera demain
demain dans la presse vit donc 19 heures
ça fait vers 17 heures peu à peu près
vers c'est ça et donc la nasa et en live
et donc on pourra suivre ça en live et
donc il ya encore un petit moment
critique au moment où le vaisseau va
s'approcher de la station où normalement
ça va ça marrer c'est il faut bien que
la jonction entre les deux ça c'est la
dernière phase on va dire oh là là par
exemple à son élan pour aller dormir
tranquille sur l'abonnement qui sont sur
la route
voilà en gros les autoroutes américaines
ou ouchik voilà tu peux dormir au volant
quasi je ne voyais pas ça chez vous bien
sûr que surtout en ce moment vu que ya
pas grand monde dehors en gros voilà
c'est tout droit passe autour de la
terre mais voilà c'est mes droits trop
il aya rien de critique mais ensuite
voilà il faut qu'ils samara la station
et là c'est plus complexe mais priori
acteurs n'y a pas de raison que ça se
fasse pas un combat demain comme symbole
mais pas de tir c'était le 30 nov aps ah
oui le pas de tir 39a à cap canaveral
c'est là d'où sont partis tout les
saturn 5 alors les saturn 5 ce sont le
nom des fusées qui renvoyaient toutes
les missions apollo donc tous les hommes
sur la lune
ensemble c'est un gros symbole et c'est
un pas de tir meetic
donc je pense que il était content de
partir de ce pas de tir là on les
comprend
moi aussi il aimerait inscrire ou
envoyer les hommes et les animaux cas
voilà c'est ça il ya pas mal de
personnes les commentaires qu'ils
avaient qui es-tu on parlait au début
justement comment on peut retrouver
justement goethe a publié pas mal de
choses sur les différents réseaux mais
nous aussi on voit là il
on se retrouve même dans plein de femmes
aiment aussi dans les médias
régulièrement on peux te retrouver
qu'est-ce que tu ne conseillerai de les
envahir dis-nous un peu à ceux qui ont
apprécié les interventions ce soir et je
les en remercie
alors je m'appelle florence porcel vous
pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux alors sur twitter à mon nom
florence porcel j'ai une page facebook
s'appelle la galaxie de florence porcel
j'ai un compte instagram qui s'appelle
ayem florence porcel mais j'espère bien
récupérer mon vrai nom sans le iam
devant ce qu'il a fait pour moi
mais on comprend pas pourquoi il veut
pas me le redonner un match nul bref
trois longueurs et tout ça alors 13h23
bref voilà vous pouvez me retrouver en
librairie et notamment il ya peut-être
un livre qui pourrait vous intéresser
aux pêcheurs mais non je n'ai pas essayé
j'ai commencé à le prendre mais ça
s'appelle l'espace sans gravité il
existe en version poche donc pas très
cher 7 8 euros
un truc comme ça et donc c'est 30
anecdotes trente et une anecdote
véridique et drôle de l'histoire du
spatial donc des astronautes d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
et puis d histoire des sciences de
l'univers donc il ya des histoires de
kaka d'astronautes et à oui parce que
les astronautes ce soir qui ont décollé
sachez le
ils ont des couches pour les enquêtes
parce que c'est l'autre bref voilà donc
je raconte un petit peu tout ça dans
l'espace sans gravité sinon comment toi
tu t'es fort mais enfin comment jeudi on
s'improvise pas j'imagine ça a pris
toutes ses connaissances comment on
devient on y boit quand on est médecin
on l'apprend d'une certaine façon mais
comment il fallait halak il faut faire
médecine
moi j'ai pas fait c'est passé non non
moi je me suis était autodidacte à la
base légale et après je me suis
professionnaliser très très vite puisque
alors et moi j'ai commencé ma carrière
sur france 5
en tant qu'animatrice mais il prenait
tout qui n'avait rien à voir avec le
spatial mais entre temps j'avais une
chaîne youtube que j'ai fermé mais qui
est toujours en ligne que vous pouvez
aller voir le trio est donc je faisais
des vidéos sur mon temps libre sur ces
thèmes-là et en fait quand j'ai quitté
france 5
je suis allé sur france inter et j'ai
fait des chroniques
voilà sur le spatial et les héros de
l'univers dans la tête au carré
je sais pas si on t'a pris comme ça
valait voilà et du coup je me suis fait
un carnet d adresses j'ai commencéà
à côtoyer des plus en plus de
scientifiques d'ingénieurs d'astronautes
et voilà et donc à force de côtoyer ces
gens là de parler avec eux de travailler
avec eux j'ai écrit mes livres en leur
posant des pas de questions en allant
vers en faisant des tas d'expériences
avec eux etc
en mx mondial ça se fait au fur et à
mesure et donc
donc voilà ça s'est fait comme ça et
donc l'aspect sans gravité ça peut vous
intéresser et on peux me retrouver aussi
sur la chaîne string theory dans une
émission qui s'appelle spécialistes et
donc comme son nom l indique que je
traite des thèmes du spatial
voilà à peu près on peut me retrouver
donc réseaux sociaux librairie va passer
par deux libraires
si vous pouvez éviter amazon qu'est ce
que vous voulez voilà mais privilégier
les libraires si vous pouvez et merci
beaucoup en florence en tout cas pour
pour cela ils vont là on a passé un bon
moment ensemble c'était il ya tout juste
une heure décollage quel lieu qu'on a
suivi en direct vous voyez encore les
images juste là pour conclure ce live
ces images
c'était il ya tout pile une heure
maintenant le décollage qui sont donc
extrêmement bien passé tout va bien tout
se passe bien dans un peu plus un peu
moins 18 heures maintenant
ils rejoindront la station spatiale là
pour l'instant c'est une longue route
dans l'espace pour qu'ils vont les mener
jusqu'à la station spatiale audrey mai
prochain bellini 8 par voilà et puis on
va tous vous souhaiter une très bonne
soirée je te remercie encore florent
parce que me pour l'invitation avec un
grand plaisir franchement bas on essaie
j'espère pour ceux qui nous regardent on
a essayé de porter vos questions chez
que ben voilà on est nombreux à
finalement regardé ces images avec
beaucoup d'admiration et sans forcément
il connaître grand chose mais c'est ce
soir de vous expliquer avec florence
même pas moi de porter moi j'ai juste
porter vos questions vis-à-vis de
florence pour que l'on puisse pas vous
expliquer que ces images vous soit
contextualiser avoir des réponses un peu
à toutes vos questions et je peux
répondre aux questions sur twitter alors
peut être pas à tout le monde mais posez
les moi et j'essaie rien il atteint
robin se lance parcelles vous pouvez la
retrouver justement sur sur twitter sont
@ voilà comme le prénom et le nom que
vous avez pu voir dans le synthé et
qu'on mettra dans l'est dans les
commentaires en description de ce live
je remercie toutes les personnes qui
nous ont suivis et que ce soit sur
facebook et sur youtube
parce que je crois que ce soir on a
atteint on a dû monter jusqu'à 40000 en
live qui ont conquis l'ensemble des deux
plateformes
des milliers de commentaires je pourrais
même pas dire combien on en est
actuellement mais sa partie un peu dans
tous les sens
le maître du temps et des horloges jce
la marée qui moi je peux quand même
commenté on a eu ce soir mais c'était
c'était bien faire coucou que les gens
voient la voix qui tu es bien de créteil
aussi con salure qu'elle a ils ont été
fabuleux parce que c'est un peu aussi en
terme d'organisation une grande première
alors je sais que pour certains mais
quelques petits soucis sonore au début
au furet justesse à très très rapidement
mais c'était aussi une grande première
aussi aujourd'hui vous voyez on a le
live on est nous dans la rédaction brut
et on vous en mets voyager aux états
unis et même jusque là parce que je
faisais là vers l'infini et l'au delà
l'au delà des commentaires j'avais 10
ans et dans les commentaires et on les
analyse oms les community managers ils
connaissent un peu l'hérault porting
statistiques qu'il faut faire tous les
mois attention le le le wen avait bien
sûr l'ordinateur ram ça va ça va être
mais je pense que c'est en design milieu
d'un grand suspens mais ça c'est encore
pire suspense que je lancement de la
fusée ma parole on n'envoie pas
d'excusés avec ses ordinateurs sur
facebook en tout cas je vais regarder je
vais regarder ça sur facebook vous dire
au moins sur youtube ça défile à une
vitesse impressionnante
on est il ya 5500 commentaires sont
faits sur youtube pense que ça du défi
encore plus de ce que j'ai vu ce que
vous êtes encore plus bavard sur youtube
c'est assez impressionnant
merci en tout cas d'avoir suivi ce live
avec nous c'est toujours plus agréable
d'être ici bat accompagner rémy que moi
derrière tout seul dans mon écran à
live-tweeter heureusement les gens ne
m'en contente pas parce que je crie
moment très fort là c'était un grand
plaisir de partager ce moment avec une
passionnée comme toi je pense que ça a
permis de le vivre intensément donc
merci encore
jusque là il nous a quittés il ya
tellement de commentaires qui s'est noyé
dans les statistiques mais mes jeux mais
je le remercie quand je remercie
ghislain voilà qui a assuré la technique
de ce live il veut pas se montrer parce
qu'il est timide mais on salue quand
même et ardo également de créteil qui
étaient là et qu'ils ont permis de
pouvoir assurer ce live merci à vous
toutes et à vous tous d'avoir suivi ce
direct le replay tout de suite vous
pourrez donc voir où en revanche que
c'est à peu près en
l'antenne à une demi heure avant vous
allez remplir plus tard et vous pouvez
voir le lancement qu'on a commenté ce
soir tout est archivé tout est en voie
disponible en replay comme à chaque fois
je vous souhaite à toutes et tous une
très bonne soirée prenez soin de vous et
puis comme vous savez la pitié ne
s'arrête jamais sur brut des vidéos qui
arrive à tout moment pour résumer
l'actualité et puis la semaine prochaine
on se retrouvera pour suivre l'évolution
de cette barre un peu moins réjouissante
crise sanitaire et économique social en
france et à l'international avec
d'autres d'autres direct pour vous
informer sur tout ça on est en train de
préparer des choses pour pouvoir vous
informer porter vos questions comme on
peut le faire depuis le début
voilà très bonne soit à vous à très
bientôt et encore merci aux amis
à très bientôt